good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson signed happy tuesday it was six
years ago and one of those
semi-hilarious moments that has
unfortunately been lost to history that
janet yellen sat through what must have
been the single most uncomfortable
congressional hearing of her life at the
time you may remember yellen was running
the federal reserve and she was as she
remains today a lifestyle liberal in
good standing
so put yourself in her position and
imagine the shock she must have felt
when members of the congressional black
caucus suggested that she janet yellen
was in fact a racist maybe even a white
supremacist what did jenny ellen do
wrong well they suggested what she did
wrong was she failed to harness the
power of the federal reserve to help
african americans
now at first yelen seem confused by this
complaint the point of the fed is to
keep the american economy stable the
point is not to pay off loyal blocks of
democratic voters and she tried to
explain this our powers she said can't
be targeted at the experience of
particular groups
that was her response but the
congressional black caucus did not buy
it
their message to janet yellen was the
same as their message to you and every
other person in this country of 350
million people do what we say we'll
denounce you as a racist
and finally janet yellen got that
message boy did she within a year yellen
had all but abandoned the traditional
constraints of monetary policy instead
there she was yammering on in public
about things like racial equity and
environmental justice
now those are issues that unlike
economics cannot be quantified or even
specifically defined and they are
therefore perfect vehicles for
power-hungry politicians hoping to
become more powerful now yellen was
supposedly an economist but as she
turned 70 she left the field of
economics completely and entered the far
more familiar world of political
activism
by the time she became joe biden's
treasury secretary the transformation
was complete among yellen's first acts
as treasury secretary was an order
changing the mission of the treasury
department's financial stability
oversight council
now that council was created by congress
after the last financial crisis as its
name suggests to prevent something
similar from ever happening again and
for about a decade it focused on
questions that might prevent another
meltdown questions like subprime lending
and automated trading on wall street
relevant questions
but under janet yellen the council
turned its attention to a far more
fashionable issue that she was consumed
with global warming
quote we must look ahead at emerging
risks yellen proclaimed climate change
is obviously the big one she sent a
letter to the world bank telling them
the same thing
as for inflation which traditionally was
a core concern of government economist
that was the emerging risk they were
worried about yellen just shrugged that
off inflation if that happened she told
us in a now famous quote it'll be quote
transitory
in the history of bad predictions from
washington which could fill volumes that
might take first place
in fact since joe biden became president
the price of gasoline has doubled and so
the prices of many other key commodities
that americans need to live
and the worst part is that not only did
janet yellen the treasury secretary
failed to see any of this coming
janet yellen more than any other single
person in america caused it in the first
place through reckless loose money
policies implemented during her years at
the fed policies that were bound to
cause inflation
and did
so if you're mad about the current state
of the economy janet yellen is probably
the first person you should blame why
does she still have her job
it's a good question
and we might have heard an answer to
that because yellen was back in front of
congress today but this time there were
no tough interrogatories from the
congressional black caucus no one called
her a racist
and said they kissed up to her as yellen
explained to a deeply sympathetic room
of members of congress the real problem
with the american economy is that she
and the democratic party don't yet have
enough control over it watch look over
the medium term the critical thing is
that we become more dependent on the
wind in the sun that are not subject to
geopolitical influences and passing
clean
energy credits that will boost
non-renewables
is i think really
really critical to
um
to to to addressing climate change and
our energy costs for households
so just for fun if you have five minutes
rewind the tape transcribe what she just
said and see if you can make sense of
the verbal bully base what are you
looking at it's called
intersectionalism it's the new religion
of government and it allows bureaucrats
when it becomes clear they have no idea
what they're doing to just pivot and
talk about something they know even less
about
so here you have janet yellen talking
about geopolitical influences clean
energy credits climate change
what is janet yellett talking about well
she has no idea
the problem is that there are people out
there who actually do understand what
she's trying to talk about experts
actual experts have studied the
sustainability of renewable energy for
years michael schellenberger for example
found that from 2011 to 2017 the cost of
solar panels dropped by more than 70
percent in this country there are more
of them it's a supply and demand
question but here's the interesting part
during that same period as the cost of
solar panels fell electricity prices in
california went up five times more than
they did in the rest of the united
states why more solar panels the solar
panels were cheaper but the electricity
they produced was more expensive huh
how does that work and how is it helping
you we know it happens because it
happened in germany at scale
from 2006 to 2018 that would be the
heyday the peak years of germany's big
renewable energy push electricity prices
went up
50 percent
now why'd that happen well let's compare
it to a neighboring country in france
electricity prices were much lower than
germany's even though france gets twice
as much of its energy from clean energy
sources as germany does
what
what made france so special how'd they
pull that off
simple nuclear france gets a lot of its
energy from nuclear power janet yellen
does not consider nuclear power a
renewable when she says renewable she
means wind and solar which by definition
are not reliable sources of energy but
they are and this is always the key
highly profitable to democratic donors
and the government of china
so of course janet yellen is for them of
course ellen didn't go into details on
why she thinks what she does because if
you unpack it if you slow down and speak
clearly it doesn't make any sense
and janet yellen knows that she's an
activist she gets that logic is
irrelevant
thinking clearly no that gets you
nowhere emotion is what carries the day
and that's why during today's
congressional hearings she started
talking about yet another topic she
knows nothing about gun crime
i am also horrified by gun violence
what we've seen in recent weeks over and
over many years and i do hope that
congress will take long overdue action
and
put in place common sense measures to
reduce gun violence
well i'm horrified about gun violence uh
i'm sorry ma'am you're the treasury
secretary shh
let's talk about the economy which is
imploding stop with your little abortion
talk your little gun talk not your area
let's get back into your lane
you're the treasury secretary
but of course she doesn't want to the
goal always is to talk about anything
other than the economy why because they
destroyed the economy but there was one
exception
at one point janet yellen was asked
because it's a pretty obvious question
how exactly as the treasury secretary
and former fed chair as an economist and
a genius
how did you miss the inflation you
caused
here it went
i said that inflation would be
transitory what i was not anticipating
was a scenario in which we would end up
contending with multiple variants of
kovid that would be
scrambling our economy in global supply
chains and i was not envisioning
impacts on food and energy prices we
have seen from russia's invasion of
ukraine so
israel powell
indicated himself
both of us probably could have used a
better term than transitory i do expect
inflation to remain high although i very
much hope that it will be coming down
now
oh so you didn't see covid coming even
though it was here for two years and we
shut down the entire economy and then
made up for the gap in productivity with
profligate government spending where we
just printed trillions of fake dollars
but you didn't think that was going to
cause inflation somehow and you didn't
think a war in the bread basket of
europe would affect food prices
let's say you were a talk show host on a
cable channel with no economic
experience whatsoever or even the
ability to balance a checkbook and it
was obvious to you
but you're the treasury secretary but
you didn't see it coming maybe you
shouldn't have called it transitory
and your answer is and we're quoting i
do expect inflation to remain high
although i do very much hope it will be
coming down oh you very much hope is
that where we are we are very much
hoping
tell us more about abortion and gun
violence if you would
blame kovid and putin and call it a day
is a joke
fox's hillary vaughn to her credit was
not convinced she asked janet yellen
whether joe biden's decision to spend
trillions of dollars might have
contributed to inflation because like
when you have more of something it's
worth less like your currency which is
almost worth less
and here was janet ellen's response
you ever warned the white house that
increased government spending could have
contributed to the inflation that we're
seeing today
okay
we're just heading to the coffee oh
go away peasant troll your inflation
talk i'm worried about climate change
and gun violence and abortion leave me
alone it's not like the treasury
secretary be gone
she should be gone this is crazy
and in a functioning country janet
yellen would be in a retirement home
somewhere writing her memoirs that no
one would ever read
but that's not what's happening she's
still the treasury secretary and that's
not what happened today
instead democrats took turns bragging
about their expensive electric cars
worried about gas prices just get a
tesla baby
here's senator debbie stabenow of
michigan
well good morning manor sector we're so
glad to have you with us i do have to
say just on the issue of
uh gas prices after waiting for a long
time to have enough trips in this
country to finally get my electric
vehicle i got it
and drove it from michigan to here uh
this last weekend and went by every
single gas station and didn't matter how
high it was and so i'm looking forward
to the opportunity for us to move to
vehicles that aren't going to be
dependent on the
whims of the oil companies and the
international markets
yes
because electric cars don't actually use
energy so they're disconnected from the
international market hey debbie seven
what's an international market you have
any idea whatsoever do you know anything
you're telling us that the oil companies
are so greedy they somehow canceled
their own leases for joining they're so
greedy they don't even want to drill oil
and that's why they shut down their own
pipelines is that right and that's why
they're talking about implementing a gas
tax
because they don't want you to use oil
right
what's the reasoning here debbie stab i
know maybe we should
contact janet yellen maybe she'll answer
maybe she'll just wave us away like the
peasants we are
what's going on here how can this person
be our treasury secretary we're in deep
waters is there anyone who can pull us
out of them
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight